pour
[Musique]
ce
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
soir les enfants
ce soir il faut être très gentil avec
nounours il est triste sevré poteau je
me sens tout mélancolie mon pauvre
nounours descend vite chez nicolas et
pimprenelle ils vont s'occuper de toi oh
oui ils savent me comprendre
mon le chef
europe
pop hip hop hop hop hop hop hop au
bon soir mais pauvre petit
qu'est ce que tu as
non je suis mélancolie to grow nonce on
va s'occuper de toi alors qu'est ce que
tu veux j'aimerais que vous me racontiez
une histoire assieds toi non
ap rhône elle apporte la livre des
petits chats
voilà
écoute bien c'est une histoire très joli
jeu vous coup fait d'auto a dit la maman
chat a surtout petit chat et elle lui
donne trois coups de salengro sur le
mets toi kodila sur les oreilles
et trois coups de langue sur son petit
bouton est comme ça il est propre et ça
tue elle était faite c'est très bien ça
ma maman s'est couché en rond dans son
panier les petits chats qui s'est mis au
chaud contre et ça ma main ils se sont
endormis lamah - s'est endormi mais pas
les petits chats ils voulaient s'amuser
nous content alors sans faire de bruit
il s'est levé il a poussé son petit nez
sur le rebord de la fenêtre
les boues ballon que voilà at il dit en
regardant la lune je vais jouer avec il
a essayé de l'attraper ce chaton en
levant mais le ballon était trop alors
le petit chat est allé d'un jardin il a
sauté sur une chaise et hop hop avec ses
petites pattes au top mais le ballon
l'une était vraiment trop alors notre
château a grimpé sur un ordre et pop top
avec ses petites communes ne pas arriver
les ballons lui mettais toujours trop
alors il est monté sur les toits de la
maison et pop avec ses petits hôtes il
promis ne réussissez pas à l'attraper il
a sauté sur la cheminée et top top avec
ses petites pattes alors à l'eau et
alors il a eu peur car ils étaient
montés trop et il nous est plus récent
le pauvre chat tout
il s'est mis à pleurer s'il faut qu'il a
réveillée jamais copié et sa maman aussi
yelle est venu le chercher avec une
grande échelle d'armement la preuve
après ça m'a mal à ramener à la maison
elle lui a donné trois coups de salengro
sur le net 3 couleurs les arrêts troc de
lang son petit menton et une batterie
coupe beaucoup
et là sagement fait dodo tu sèmes
nounours qu'elle était jolie votre
histoire
merci le petit à la quête d'un tuner
plus mélancolique où l'eau sur trois vit
car il est à nous on va se coucher tout
seul bones une annonce bonne nuit bonne
nuit
[Musique]
oui
mais le nouveau logo alors nounours
comment se porte la mélancolie je fume
pas trop nicolas et pimprenelle m'ont
raconté une jolie histoire
pauvre petit chat mieux ou ou un route
je vous la raconte re quand vous aurez
le cafard pas trop d'accord d'accord
nounours bonne nuit les enfants fêtes de
bourg
[Musique]
oh
où